the first realization that there were
actually distinct layers of the earth
came from this guy right over here
andrija mohorovic and i apologize ahead
of time to any croatians for
butchering any of the pronunciation and
he was a meteorologist and a
seismologist and he was the first one to
notice in 1909
when there was an earthquake
there was an earthquake in croatia
a little bit southeast of zagreb so the
earthquake was roughly over here and
lucky for him and lucky for us before
that earthquake there was actually a
bunch of seismographic stations already
in the area and all these seismographic
stations are are they essentially
instruments were installed so that if
there was any essentially seismic waves
passing they would be able to measure it
when the waves got there and what was
interesting about this andreja realized
that if you had a if if the entire earth
was just kind of a uniform material so
let me let's draw that scenario it would
get denser as you go down and so you
would have kind of this refraction this
continuous refraction or these curved
paths happening but he realized that
let's say we had an earthquake right
over here so this is the uniform case
uniform
uniform layer only one layer although it
does get denser then the closer the
closer you are to the earthquake so
waves would get there first then waves
would get over there then waves would
get over there and these are the these
are the the body waves these are the
ones that are traveling through the
earth's crust but in general the further
you are away from the earthquake or the
time it takes for the waves to get to a
point is going to be proportional to the
distance that point is away from the
earthquake so you would expect to see
something like this so if you were to
plot on the horizontal axis if you were
to plot distance
and on the vertical axis you were to
plot time
time
you should see something like this you
should see a straight line and that's
just because you're going it's traveling
roughly the same velocity along any of
these arcs it's maybe getting a little
bit faster as it's getting deeper but
roughly the same velocity is traveling
along these arcs and the distance of
these arcs are proportional to the
distance along the surface along the
distance of the surface so essentially
the time is going they're all traveling
roughly at the same velocity and they're
just traveling different distances so
the time it takes is just going to be
proportional to the distance but he
noticed something interesting
when he actually measured when the
different when the waves from that
earthquake reached different
seismographic stations he saw something
interesting so let me so this is the
theoretical if we had a kind of this
uniform one layered earth but he saw
something interesting so once again this
is distance
and this right over here is time
and at 200 kilometers at 200 kilometers
away from the earthquake so until 200
kilometers he saw exactly what you would
expect from a uniform earth it was just
the time took was proportional to the
distance but at 200 kilometers he saw
something interesting all of a sudden
the waves were reaching there faster the
slope of this line changed it took less
time for each incremental distance so
for some reason the waves that were
going at these farther stations the
stations that were more than 200
kilometers away the stations somehow
they were accelerated somehow they were
able to move faster and he's the one
that realized that this was because the
waves that we're getting to these
further stations must have traveled
through a more dense layer of the earth
so let's just think about it
so if we have a more dense layer it will
fit this information right over here
so if we have a layer like this
which we now know to be the crust and
then you have a denser layer which we
now know to be the mantle
then what you would have is
so you have your earthquake right over
here they're closer by while you're
still within the crust it would be
proportional
it would be proportional and then let's
say that this is exactly this right here
is 200 kilometers away but then if you
go any further the waves would have to
travel
so that they would travel so they would
go like this and then they would get
refracted even harder so they would get
refracted even so they would be a little
bit curved
ahead of time but then they're going
into a much denser material or it's not
gradually dense it's actually kind of a
a all of a sudden a considerably more
dense material so it'll get refracted
even more
and then it'll go over here and since it
was able to travel all of this distance
in a denser material it would have
traveled faster along this path and so
it would get to this this distance on
the surface that's more than 200
kilometers away it would get there it
would get there faster and so he said
that there must be there must be a
denser a denser layer that those waves
are traveling through which we now know
to be the mantle
and and the boundary between what we now
know to be the crust and this denser
layer which is we now know to be the
mantle is actually named after him it's
called the moho mohorov vichik
discontinuity and sometimes it's just
called the moho for short so that
boundary between the custom the mantle
is now named for him but this was a huge
discovery because not only was he able
to
tell us based on the data based on kind
of indirect data just you know based on
earthquakes happening and measuring when
the earthquakes reach different points
of the earth that there probably is a
denser layer and if you do that mat do
the math under continental crust that
denser layer is about 35 kilometers down
he was able to tell us that there is
that layer but even more importantly he
was able to give the clue that just
using information from earthquakes we
could we could essentially figure out
the actual composition of the earth
because no one has ever dug that deep no
one has ever dug into the mantle much
less the outer core or the inner core in
the next few videos we're going to kind
of take this insight that we can use
information from earthquakes to actually
think about how we know that there is an
outer liquid core and that there's an
inner core as well and then obviously
you could keep going and think about all
of the different densities within the
mantle and all that i won't go into that
much detail but i'll see in the next
video